[Musica]
un uomo si prefigura il compito di
disegnare il volto passo bianchi e
popolano spazio di immagini di montagna
i pali di pesci di astri di strumenti di
cavalli di moglie prima di morire scopre
che questo paziente labirinto di me e ha
tracciato i lineamenti del suo volto
questo sono io
siete voi perché questo labirinto di lì
è una delle possibili definizioni
descrizioni para dare soluzioni di quel
caos che ci necessario di quel casco
swisscom per l'ordine provvisorio che si
chiama di tanta si va da dove partire
affrontare il tema del carso voglio
partire da una macchia perché credo che
il caso se anche una marcia è una verità
di linea o dentro le linee linea linea e
di corsive linee circolari che ho tratto
qui il tema della teoria dei giochi
dell'albero della vita altrimenti di
mary fisici le neuroscienze
ma la lettura naturalmente teatro
dobbiamo da sempre di vita
e siccome il moto e carico di vita
l'annunciazione principia da serie di
eventi
si dice che non fund è nato di cui dirò
fra poco e bene sarai contatto partire
da una macchia una macchia precedente
alla scomparsa di la nava cabine nel
1519 la macchia di 1.549 a vedenti e
descrive tal atto francesco toni
racconta di una pittura era pittore di
paesaggi e c'è una macchia di un paese
la si guarda da vicino e avrebbe due
personaggi una scena così teatrale è uno
dei numerici che di quella macchia vede
o intravede uomini testi di uomini cose
fantastiche l'altro fianco vede anche
una nuvola tre donne e dentro queste
nuove vedete rimani fantastici dei porti
delle sicure
dunque il primo e al secondo domanda ma
tu credi che in quella nuvola presi da
parte di quello che andrebbe si rapporti
figure la nato risponde no e come voglia
chiamare c che ridiventa quella dove
fantasia immaginazione caps del cervello
lato risponde castelli nine mile
specifica 49 a questa affermazione quasi
elementare non potremo trasmettere i
nostri bambini e molto serie che per
schemi a 10
significa che ascoltate significa che
dobbiamo confrontarci con castelli
interna d'arresto poco dopo verso fine
di quel secolo sarà scelto a far
incontrare uno studente di logico ratio
di fronte a un letto dopo che hanno
visto da fantasma del padre a dire ci
sono più cose in cielo e terra che tutti
i soldi delle cosche sofia orazi
colorati si era stupito ci fosse il
giorno e le rotte da cui ableton ha
detto benvenuto stranieri e distruggere
italiana se poniamo il caso che il caos
è dentro di noi come una straniera che
fosse la fonte dare nel caos cominciò da
una porta e da va bene come sapere nella
genesi 11 ma di questo forse ci sarebbe
pure lo più tardi dunque 1.149 ma cosa
era successo e vedo quindi chi mi ha
invitata da dietro tutto mi anche la
twitter per questa mia vita dedicata
alla nato è anche una volta è il mio e
il vostro maestro
facciamo un salto prima a fine 400 non
arte giovani della bottega del
verrocchio vicino a un altro personaggio
si chiama botticelli non so se mi spiego
sarà botticelli e sembra che ci sia già
un visibilmente la migrazione delle
figure che si amano renzo lorenzo de
medici botticelli prende una spugna
imbevuta di colori e la cerchia futuro
da questo muro poi corrono i colori e
leonardo osserva questa ce l'ha se ne
ricorderanno di se ne ricordava tempo
dentro ma non più giovane ma l'ha dato
dal rock e non è ancora arrivato minardi
la prima del 1482 e approcciare che vide
da dirci che sta studiando le leggi
della natura il modo il peso la forza la
perfusione sta studiando l'acqua che
c'entrano con casco che l'acqua è quanto
ci sono solo i dubbi avete evitato
l'acqua prima il calcio più fare collana
e ci arrivi ebbene e di rado avanti
questo pensiero che ho recuperato
frettolosamente provata re più o meno
come sempre a memoria dice non è spresal
questo mio parere si rifarà ricordato di
aver paura di fermati a vedere nelle
macchie di muri nella celere de force
negli nuvoli le nuvole e di facili e
sebbene siano in te compreso tutto per
hai detto di essi invenzioni mira
bellissime e poco dopo quasi nello
stesso testo dice per dalle cose del
pane rosa dalle fasi confuse li vigente
si resta a nuove invenzioni e quindi io
sono subito si ricolleghi tema più caldo
perché delle cose che aggiunge il nostro
cielo si sveglia si testa a nuove non è
invenzione a nuove invenzioni perché in
quella macchia sul muro perché vede
cerca il fuoco perché l'infarto perché
un umore cosa ci vuole dire ritornato
nella sua tesi di serie la tesi che così
e anche a noi con di carmine perché
pittore non potevano diventare cicatrici
sacco il pittore o se preferite perché
il pittore leonardo e scienziato e
scultore ingegnere architetto botanico
la tua vista e di cattolico e di core
design del ritmo di teatro e se tra da
pesce tra come si muove quindi il
pensierino nato da queste magie da saper
ne detto ne manchi un movimento un
movimento che ci porta da motori
all'altro da un sistema all'altro se
volete da un centro all'altro e questa
transizione questo movimento che noi
dobbiamo assecondare alcune delle
scoperte scientifiche di donati che non
ero ancora scienza che la scelta da
ancora rivali studia il suo metodo sia
permesso il cielo da uno sguardo alla
botanica e non si ferma descrizione sui
colori o fisica si ferma a guardare
disegni tropismo sapere cos'è il
trofismo cioè il movimento di una pianta
tirata dalla luce ombra di grazie della
linfa che fa sì che ci sia più linfa
nell'aria sotto le luci rispetto a
quelli che sono sotto l'ombra questa è
il caos
segue leonardo questo nella vita oppure
in giro chi e cosa fai ti rigira una
roccia stoffa nato nel passare del tempo
stratificazione veloce nuova per fornire
questo è il caos nella materia o ancora
quando guarda i cerchi concentrici e
sarà la cifra delle tac sono fossile
sulla cocchiglia cosa fuori da nardò
genere quando guarda mamma di un volo
l'amatori cella 14 touch in clinica
celeri fuga delle forze gli autonomi che
non sono fatto ordinari
lineari e che cambiano a seconda della
serie di variabili perché non ti chiama
che caos condire c'erano casualità
evoluzione e l'interazione con variabili
e vere di questo percorso per la
doccetta uno sguardo anche a nato ben
sette che si pensi st diversi nel
diastro nomi che da un errore oppure
ancora si ferma sulla fisica ed i pezzi
della fisica che oggi sia protagonista
credo che la vera stata ritrovarci la
terza l'ex pilota che audizione cira
reazioni o ancora potremmo fermarci
tornando come sue sempre scoperte prima
delle scoperte quando si muove
sull'ottica sull'acustica sulla natura
ondulatoria della loro cella natura
appunto la storia del suono
questo è allenato per sé e per allergie
si avvicinano il fenomeno all'altro è
evidente che era un fenomeno all'altro
che sono spesso di nord chiusi cercarsi
c'è ancora una confusione c'è il
prezioso insieme di elementi non
intercetta ma nuova il calcio è
esattamente questo è quello che ci serve
anche mi si permette in un approccio
politico con lo straniero questa maniera
cioè con la diverso da noi le dobbiamo
approcciarci sono che questi termini
sapendo che il cas e nietzsche e
l'albero e l'incertezza e li compiono
per completezza di cui abbiamo bisogno
per affrontare
leggete qui siamo fine se stesse lecce
quindi diamo giudiziari le ricezioni in
se stesse sistemi chiusi che non ci
porta da nessuna parte
infatti chiaro se
un incidente una frattura che permette
il sistema chiuso di affreschi fretta
raj della nuova energia ma troviamo
velocemente al tema dell'acqua
quello che capisci che l'acqua è tutto
che capisce che un sistema dove la somma
del partito del punto era sopra delle
parti e meno del tutto 23 per caso la
terza che dobbiamo tener conto dell'uno
e dell'altro dell'arma dice acqua in fra
quattro elementi secondo più debole di
meno volubilità ritrova ma irene si non
si connette solidi timone merito acqua
percorso dell'anima fra circoletto la
luogo percorso più lunga distanza la
voce facendoli tra l'aria bidone
distacca la voce facili in francia più
rompere stanza la voce fascicoli fra
l'universo ma poiché navette definita
non sia stette in franzoni finì lì
questo è dovuto l'atto qualcosa
dell'anima come se ti amo oggi nel
rapporto tra caos e ordine che i portici
in fondo è uno dei realizzata conoscete
ma questo così diventa vortice quanto
prima c'è stata una turbolenza una
turbolenza che traggo in acqua con un
movimento lineare la mente a muoversi la
rende circolante poi sappiamo anche che
la debolezza
andrà a perdere energia i 12 e poi
superare fino a quando ci sarà una nuova
turbolenze almeno nove morti ce scoperte
di fine anno 200 a dividere i 122 era un
altro lavora supporti ci sta una
turbolenza e la scritta da scritto però
vi dico di fini secondo guardando
proprio l'acqua
ricordo che l'acqua di terra e fuoco si
ricorda alimenti naturali stiamo
parlando di natura ci prova dai casi
altra natura
no no decisi io non dico io
nasce quindi sfruttare con store datec
imperiali dovremo fare i conti con
questo sfruttare dovremo fare i conti
con la terra per oltre conti con la
piedi anche questa epoca
però faccio foto di queste legge perché
siamo noi difficile si aprono in questi
ci siamo noi che siamo una variante
dentro con il flusso di natura e
richieste apriamo da trasformiamo più
mettiamo a costruirla non si chiama noi
stessi
ebbene in questa direzione perché
leonardo si sofferma osservando ad
esempio delle cascate dice e
descriveranno compiuti 60 accessibili
vi risparmiamo santana ciechi che è
stato 80 secondi io ho un minuto 50 per
un posso farlo però devo dire che dice
votazione esportazioni bollori movimenti
rigori ricadenti equità e qualità
precipizi marmorini strepiti ruine i
flussi nel risorgimento sovvertimenti
della giustizia reali fumetti riattiva
20 sia pregiati venezia toronto celerità
e se desidera perché tanto forte perché
c'è un solo meglio dei tavoli comincia a
prendere una forma dentro uno spettatore
quindi bisogna descrivere il caos sulla
base
della relazione tra la legge l'incidente
tra la legge e l'aria tra le reti che
certezza quando c'è un genio nando
l'accusa da pseudo fuori le storie
dell'arte se nonostante la scienza lieve
lasciati più te alcune sue opere e
perché la volontà del ciclismo più ha
lasciato la porta aperta perché potesse
entrare un incidente l'area di certezza
magari più caos si chiama ombra è quello
per sé quel punto lo sfumato che poi
diventerà vettura e prospettiva l'ombra
fra la prospettiva nella storia
dell'arca dalla quale da quella macchia
di prima avremo city permettete
impressionismo espressionismo astratto
l'informale e dettagli di signore che si
chiama non c'è fontana e burri la
spazialità della materia da qui noi
facendo incontri contrarsi allora
concludo partire ci allena da un fine ma
le vittorie scienziata è semplicemente
ciò che il caso vuole che tutti siamo
due loro come noi siamo inventori e
siamo intenti force specie siamo troppi
interni ti propongo per essere inventori
del nostro calcio
grazie
[Applauso]